i have 85 do i have 90. i have 90 from
the man with the face at table 4.
this is terrible you don't know what
you're doing adam sandler
yeah that's right i collect antiquities
i'm a serious person
i'm writing a movie right now about the
russian revolution oh really who does
kevin james play in it
uh-huh it's a serious movie trotsky
ah there it is but he's got a wife who
never wears a bra i think you're gonna
like it
thanks for dressing up by the way all
right back to this plate i think you
could use it for a variety of things
new item up there uh how much you guys
want to pay for me to stick my socks in
this moron's mouth i will
did football legend joe theismann just
bid a thousand dollars to put a sock in
my mouth
you bet okay but let's get it going a
little seriously back to the porno
please
uh 1200 bucks sucking them out okay the
idiot gets ready
for i'd say 1300 would be even better
1300 joel deisman coming in
oh i got 39 25 000.
[Applause]
so the joey thighsman congratulations
you're getting a sock in your mouth
1300 bucks joe theismann can i stick the
sock in his mouth i'll pay extra
yes you may because i just sold my item
to the man in the great shirt at table
18.
nypd you're under arrest heading your
way
[Music]
gotcha my lake my lake
you broke my other leg uh oh this was
supposed to be a
safe event nothing to see here except
for
the bone oh sticking out of the leg joe
i videoed it hey here's someone who may
be able to convince you hello mrs obama
hey grant how you doing doing good this
is leslie knope she's considering a job
with us running the new midwest bureau
in chicago
well you know how i feel about chicago
you are from chicago so you like it
that's right and we need passionate
people like you in our national parks
you know they get hundreds of millions
of visitors each year
are you nodding because you agree with
me yes i do agree with you
i agree with you on all things
throughout history until the end of time
forever
you and grant work together yeah we work
together a lot he's helped me integrate
the let's move program into our national
parks you know
getting kids outside rock climbing
hiking wow that's really really
incredible great work
i'm sorry i'm talking so loud i'm
getting louder now and i can't stop my
apologies
just i don't know just can i high five
my high five
yeah well i hope you take the job change
happens
one person at a time good to meet you
[Applause]
again think it over
[Laughter]
this is the world famous rockefeller
center founded of course by theodore
rockefeller
this is a skating rink and i think the
rangers
practice there sometimes and it's
that's teen effect that's tina fey from
saturday night live
hello hello hi oh i'm i'm sorry
i thought you were okay
she looked like she looked a lot like
tina fey
hello hello i thought that was tina fey
but it wasn't
so are you serious he was here
when when i was talking to the fake tina
fey come on
sir i have all the latest seinfeld
vision promos wonderful
what's seinfeld vision well i realized
that nbc
owns hundreds of hours of footage of
seinfeld from his massively successful
television series
seinfeld so my old tech guys were able
to digitally capture
seinfeld and now we can basically make
him do or say whatever we want
so for the month of october all of our
primetime shows will feature a
computerized guest appearance from
mr jerry seinfeld if you didn't kill her
why didn't you stay quit grilling me
save the cheerleader save the world
yeah that's what i said
i'll take that deal
[Music]
does jerry seinfeld know you're doing
this uh jerry's in europe with his
family right now but by the time he gets
back seinfeld vision will be a monster
hit and his kids will go to school
and their friends will say i really
loved your dad in that episode of medium
last night and he's
he's gonna love it though how can i help
you jerry jack i was vacationing with my
family in europe in a country only rich
people know about
sanborgia no better but i can't tell you
anyway my mother called to tell me that
i'm gonna be on law and order
and er cause i called my agent to find
out
when did i shoot these things that's the
beauty of this jerry it's all done with
computers when you see it you're gonna
love it
25 sexy moms 50 sweaty 8th grade boys
and one beloved american comedy star
this wednesday on milf island really
is that really your pitch genuine it is
an honor
to be breathing the same air as you no
joke but real talk
we're both men about town being
constantly bombarded with party
invitations
who is this guy my friend who's opening
a restaurant tonight and you're going to
be there cousin
unless you want me to get on stage and
talk about how we used to take baths
together
how you cried whenever i took away your
rubber duckies damn
donna why you got to bring the quacks
and five into this
how y'all doing little sebastian this
one is for you
because you're my pony
[Applause]
you can't just sit here and cry oh i
can't so just sit here and cry
two million hits in the first week and
then the parodies started one from the
philippines got 12 million hits
and the late night comedy guys had a
field day with it
[Applause]
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be
all right
update i'm seth myers that's baby
goodnight
[Applause]
these spindles are gorgeous and there's
almost a feeling of
musculature to this transition the oak
just sort of
told me the shape before i even got to
the spoke shave this under bevel is a
great trick it really makes it feel
lighter while leaving you plenty of beef
to carve
it's really just a modified danish line
still you made it your own
this is as good a chair as i've seen i
have nothing left
to teach you oh hurrah
thank you
almost forgot i did get you them two
some hits too
ooh snap that's an even better gift
that's not all
look behind you but don't be obvious
could i get
uh the me softshell crab
josh groban he's eating his own sushi
that's the most baller thing i've ever
seen
so you've just been bought by sabre
probably a lot of questions
hi i'm christian slater what's it like
to work for sabre
let's find out together working at sabre
means taking on the challenge of the
road that rises to meet you
savor respecting the past
but opening the window to the future
have you ever tasted a rainbow and savor
you will
you'll find it easy to embrace the saber
spirit
welcome we're very excited to go on this
journey with you
so you've been shown a nonsensical video
you're probably wondering
what's going on well you're not alone
quality welders
how did you do this call in a few favors
excuse me
a few hundred favors mr vice president
ben wyatt from congressman murray's
office then dave told me you're gonna be
coming by and you must be leslie knope
welcome
welcome
my my name just came out of your mouth
well yeah it did
this isn't happening this this isn't
real no it's it's happening
and i'm delighted to have you here on
behalf of the president myself
oh mr vice president i am deeply
flattered but there's no way that i
could take over madam secretary
clinton's position
i mean i'm confident you could do that
job or any other but okay we will
well the reason you're here is i'm told
you've done such a
great job in your town and the state of
indiana and i just want to say
congratulations for your public service
i just want to say thank you well you
you're very welcome you're very welcome
thank you you're you're very welcome
you're
you're very handsome i think we're all
done well you're very nice but thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much we'll see you tomorrow well
oh you will thank you mr vice president
you're welcome you don't let anything
happen to him do you understand me
he is precious cars
you